plus de 25 ans après l'arrivée des OGM
en agriculture de nouvelles semences
issues du génie génétique inquiète les
producteurs biologiques pour calmer
leurs inquiétudes l'industrie promet la
transparence elle s'engage à divulguer
la nature de ces nouvelles semences mais
comme pour les OGM classique aucun
étiquetage réglementaire n'est prévu
alors est-ce que ce sera suffisant pour
relever le défi de la traçabilité et
comment les consommateurs feront-ils
pour s'y retrouver
c'est vraiment important de continuer
seul OGM et ça c'est semences là
il y a des nouvelles technologies qui
arrivent l'édition génique qui peuvent
apporter des solutions très importantes
pour le secteur agricole
c'est modification ou de ces changements
là et bien ce n'est pas acceptable
il faut toujours se méfier de ceux qui
nous promet tous les malheurs avec ça
mais de ceux qui nous promettent tous
les bonheurs avec ça aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois l'histoire se répète
tout comme les premiers OGM les
nouvelles semences issues du génie
génétique alimente les débats
pourquoi les utiliser y a-t-il des
risques comment les identifier les
détecter doit-on les étiqueter les mêmes
questions refont surface et pour les
producteurs du secteur biologique
l'enjeu et colossal
nous on vous consulte
poser sans OGM donc ça vaut quand même
être un défi genre de voir que mettre la
certification vous pouvez voir vos
réajuste à nouveau là parce que on va
vraiment être pris entre l'arbre et
l'Écosse
et le fier représentant de la septième
génération d'agriculteurs avec son
grand-père son père et ses oncles il
multiplie les précautions pour produire
du lait certifié biologique et éviter la
contamination par les OGM les organismes
génétiquement modifiés l'arrivée de ces
nouvelles semences pourrait compromettre
sa certification
qu'on fait c'est tout en production
biologique donc c'est vraiment important
les vaches mangent vraiment des aliments
biologiques puis dans le Cheb comme
étant donné que Zelda sont biologiques
mais il y a aucun pesticides toutes les
allumettes sont sans objet
dans la filière biologique les règles de
certification sont bien claires tous les
OGM sont interdits de même que tous les
produits obtenus par Jenny génétique
l'amélioration des végétaux c'est la
spécialité de Dominique Michaud un
OGM dans le langage de tous les jours
c'est un organisme transgénique
c'est-à-dire un organisme dans lequel on
a introduit un laboratoire de nouveaux
matériels qui étaient pas là au départ
tandis que l'édition génique on ajoute
pas de nouveaux matériels donc le
résultat ce sont des mutations des
petits changements ponctuels comme on
génère faire l'amélioration
conventionnelle
et c'est justement dans cette catégorie
qu'entre ces nouvelles semences qui
inquiète Gabriel Landeron
des semences produites grâce à des
innovations récentes comme le scalpel
moléculaire crisper un outil qui a
conquis les laboratoires partout dans le
monde grâce à sa simplicité
d'utilisation
ça permet d'aller beaucoup plus
rapidement et de façon beaucoup plus
précise choisissons la pomme de terre
par exemple c'est extrêmement difficile
de d'améliorer génétiquement la pomme de
terre par les voies conventionnelles à
cause de la complexité son génome alors
que pour l'édition génique cette
question là se pose pas on est capable
d'aller changer directement le ou les
gènes qui sont impliqués dans le
caractère qu'on veut moduler moi je
pense que c'est pas des OGM et la pomme
de terre n'est qu'un exemple parmi tant
d'autres
au cours de la dernière décennie en
laboratoire des chercheurs ont utilisé
divers outils d'édition des gènes sur
des plantes comme le riz la tomate le
maïs le soya ou le blé pour modifier des
caractères comme le rendement la
croissance la résistance aux maladies à
la sécheresse à l'anthroposage améliorer
aussi la valeur nutritionnelle la
couleur la saveur ou la conservation des
aliments et bien sûr parfois pour
stimuler la résistance aux herbicides un
caractère qui n'est pas sans rappeler
les OGM sauf que dans ce cas-ci les
semences ne contiennent pas de matériel
génétique provenant d'une autre espèce
l'édition dynamique le son nom le dit on
joue dans les gènes quand même donc pour
moi ça reste une manipulation génétique
terrain de la filière biologique Loïc de
Wavrin est un des co-fondateurs de la
Coop Agrobio du Québec depuis des années
il multiplie les efforts pour soutenir
les producteurs de son secteur
on veut s'assurer que lorsqu'on
introduit des nouvelles technologies on
n'est pas de risques à long terme on
s'est rendu compte des effets négatifs
de certains herbicides ou bien de la
tolérance des mauvaises herbes la façon
de la mauvaise herbe à s'adapter à ses
herbicides là donc on est obligé de
maintenir de mélanger plusieurs sortes
d'herbicides ensemble pour arriver à
avoir de l'effet
c'est peut-être possible que ça arrive
de la même façon au niveau de ces
technologies
et l'impact sur les exportations tous
les pays ne sont pas alignés de la même
façon au niveau de l'acceptation de ces
technologies là donc le jour où vous
voulez exporter un grain dans lequel il
y a une modification ou un changement au
niveau de son génome vous allez vous
heurter à des barrières au niveau de
l'exportation de ces produits là
des barrières qui sont bien réelles
entre autres en Europe
là-bas la plupart des pays considèrent
ces nouvelles semences comme des OGM
mais peut-être pas pour longtemps car
partout dans le monde les promoteurs de
ces innovations frappent aux portes des
agences réglementaires on a commencé des
démarches
importantes autour de 2015-2016 on
voyait
que ça s'en venait puis on vous laisse
assurer que la porte sera pas fermée aux
nouvelles technologies
au Canada tout comme dans bon nombre de
pays c'est l'organisation crop Life qui
représente l'industrie de la
phytoprotection et des biotechnologies
végétales
[Musique]
c'est que les coûts de développement
sont beaucoup moins que des technologies
précédentes comme les
OGM par exemple
avec les années les démarches ont fini
par porter fruit depuis 2020 aux
États-Unis les semences issus des
nouvelles biotechnologies ne sont plus
considérées comme des OGM à moins de
contenir un gène étranger et le Canada
pourrait bientôt emboîter le pas
[Musique]
une situation qui inquiète Daniel
lamperon responsable des cultures à la
ferme familiale qui a pris le virage bio
il y a 20 ans déjà
sa préoccupation c'est l'identification
s'il nous amène un nouveau produit qu'on
peut pas identifier sur votre encore
plus difficile pour nous autres ça
prendra une réglementation sur la
traçabilité sur l'identification des
produits
issus de la modification génétique
des services conseils au centre
d'expertise et de transfert en
agriculture biologique la Grenoble
Muriel Bournival accompagne les
producteurs de grandes cultures notre
préoccupation par rapport à ces nouveaux
types de transformation c'est vraiment
au niveau de la détection si les
nouvelles technologies sont pas
détectables en amont on peut ne plus
savoir ce qu'on achète et ce qu'on
produit donc c'est puis au final c'est
le consommateur qui peut être drimé
pour calmer les inquiétudes l'automne
dernier la ministre fédérale de
l'Agriculture et de l'Agroalimentaire
Marie-Claude Bibot a pris un engagement
formel on veut de la traçabilité
ilité intégration de la certification
bio j'ai très bien compris le message de
mon assurance
de son côté l'industrie promet la
transparence les plantes issues de
éditions
très clairement indiqué dans les bases
de données dans les guides de semences
comment on fait avec les OGM alors des
producteurs la traçabilité la
transparence va continuer dans de
nouveaux systèmes sur une base
volontaire c'est tout ça toujours été
l'industrie qui donne l'information
parce que c'est des informations sur le
marché et non sur la santé sécurité
alors c'est un système qui est géré par
l'industrie puis qui a toujours qui
existe depuis 25 ans pas sûr qu'on
puisse se fier entièrement aux
déclarations volontaires de l'industrie
sur ce sujet le passé n'est pas garant
de l'avenir mais on peut avoir des
doutes quand même alors si on regarde
les catalogues si l'émission c'est qu'au
fil des ans Loïc de Wavrin a pu
constater que ce qui déclaré ne
correspond pas toujours à la réalité il
faut faire attention lorsque l'on aime
lorsqu'on des semences qui ne sont pas
OGM s'assurer que celle-ci ne soit pas
contaminée par des OGM donc il y a des
tests à faire pour s'assurer de ça il y
arrive certains situations où les
semences ne peuvent pas être utilisés en
régie biologique parce que on retrouve
des traces de contamination même si
elles sont identiques comme étant sans
OGM absolument
si des tests permettent de détecter des
OGM dans les semences avec l'édition des
gènes c'est une autre paire de manche ça
va être très difficile d'encore
on introduit des petites modifications
ponctuelles dans le génome qui sont
identiques aux mutations qui surviennent
dans la nature puis aux mutations aussi
on obtient en faisant des croisements
donc c'est difficilement envisageable
déterminer de une un mode de traçabilité
pour ça puisque les différences entre
sont pas là en fait ils sont pas
toujours pas détectables
d'emblée même l'industrie de l'admet la
traçabilité assez limite le fait qu'on
n'insère pas de marqueurs ou de
changement génétique de notre plante il
y a pas de façon de détecter mais les
semences que les producteurs s'aiment de
la transparence va être très clair de
quel variété contient quel caractère de
d'édition génique
à moins de savoir précisément ce qu'on
cherche détecter des traces d'édition
dans un génome c'est tout le temps sinon
plus difficile que de trouver une
aiguille dans une botte de foin
là on ajoute si vous voulez une autre
une autre couche de complexité à la
modification génétique et une autre
couche je dirais de d'invisibilité si
vous voulez de ces produits là non
seulement dans le sur le marché mais
dans les assiettes des consommateurs
avant d'être sociologue Elisabeth
Abergel a été formé en biologie
moléculaire végétale aujourd'hui sa
spécialité c'est la réglementation et
les impacts des organismes génétiquement
modifiés les gens ne sont pas informés
sur ces questions là donc en fait ils
vont se retrouver à acheter des produits
à consommer des produits dont ils ne
connaîtront absolument rien mais ne
connaîtront pas leur origine et la
manière dont ils ont été produits en
fait
après les OGM ces nouvelles semences de
la discorde l'amène encore une fois à
s'interroger sur le rôle des
technologies en agriculture il faut se
demander pourquoi est-ce qu'on a besoin
de cette technologie là plutôt de que de
d'essayer de produire des plantes qui
résistent la sécheresse plutôt que de
créer des technologies qui qui traitent
des symptômes des changements
climatiques aller voir directement
quelles sont les causes et changements
climatiques et aller voir quels sont les
solutions potentielles qui auraient
peut-être le moins d'impact sur
l'environnement
c'est sûr qu'on veut pas travailler avec
des semences comme ça ou une technologie
comme ça parce que nous dans nos valeurs
c'est travailler avec la nature et pas
en modifier sa nature là donc pour nous
c'est vraiment important d'être capable
de se procurer des semences qui sont
sans se gêner génétique
[Musique]
depuis le tournage de ce reportage tout
le monde attend que le gouvernement
fédéral publie les lignes directrices
entourant la mise en marché de ces
nouvelles semences pour savoir lesquels
devront faire l'objet d'une évaluation
et comment leur présence sera signalé
pour garantir leur traçabilité